felicidad a pesar de la desgracia una
familia se reunió después de sufrir la
separación a causa de las inundaciones
que afectan el estado brasileño de bahía
es una alegría saber que lograron cruzar
hacia este lado gracias a dios estamos
en paz este grupo familiar es parte de
las 600.000 personas que han sido
afectadas por las fuertes lluvias que
azotan la región desde el mes pasado
dejando un saldo de al menos 20
fallecidos unas 50.000 personas
desplazadas y un panorama devastador
estábamos muy asustados era catastrófico
aquí en la calle cuando llegué a la casa
tenía agua hasta el ombligo había mucha
agua cuando llegué las casas aún no se
habían derrumbado entonces todo cayó
debe haber 15 casas destruidas aquí
perdimos todo todos aquí se quedaron sin
nada según el centro nacional de
monitoreo y alerta de desastres
naturales este ha sido el período más
intenso de lluvias para el estado de 15
millones de habitantes en los últimos 32
años las cifras se revelan que ha
llovido 5 veces lo que sería normal para
del año según el gobernador de bahía
ruiz castro se necesitan un equivalente
a 70 millones de dólares para construir
unas 5000 viviendas destinadas a los
damnificados